dans ce bois tout près de saint cyr les
colons monique olivier l'ex compagne de
michel fourniret
la juge d'instruction et les enquêteurs
sont restés une bonne partie de l'après
midi
décidé à coopérer selon son avocate
monique olivier at elle indiqué
l'endroit où des indices pour tenter de
trouver marie angèle domèce la justice
cherche toujours le corps de cette jeune
femme handicapée âgée de 19 ans quand
elle a disparu en 1988 dans l'yonne
monique olivier a accusé son mari de ce
meurtre est le tueur en série a fini par
avouer il y a quelques mois plus tôt
dans l'après midi le convoi s'est rendu
dans un bois au milieu des vignes de
saint bris le vineux sur les indications
de l'ex compagne de michel fourniret
là encore difficile de l'affirmer pour
l'heure rien ne filtre des opérations en
cours
après michel fourniret la semaine
dernière la justice espère faire avancer
l'enquêté
avec la venue dans l'yonne de monique
olivier des opérations doit se
poursuivre demain